[Music]
why are you pointing at things
ah geez i can't wait for this show to be
over
everybody's driving me crazy
shut up
happy friday you friday freaks it's day
five of our no audience shows i'm
starting to understand how chris hayes
feels
the dork
that kid i know i don't so it appears
that joe's got no time to think as his
ratings continue to shrink a new poll
shows a measly 11 percent of adults
believe biden is a very strong leader
the same 11 also think tiger woods is a
scary place for a picnic
uh that's like a rob o'neill joke
meantime 57 percent of respondents
that's a majority cats
call him a weak leader but if the
president were standing here today would
he say he's never given any free time or
any time to think
if he were standing here today which i
know he's always invited he's what you
guys will say but he would say we never
give him any free time or any time to
think
um
so that's why his pull out of
afghanistan seemed so thoughtless
really no time to think despite all
those trips back to delaware i mean what
else is there to do on amtrak marvel at
how slow it is or how much it costs
what is he doing boring aids with the
story of how he stood up to corn pop or
reading charlotte's web for the 85th
time or is the conductor letting him
steer the choo choo
i mean there's only so much sniffing of
children's hair and eating ice cream you
can do
or is it sniffing ice cream and eating
children's hair or is it eating ice
cream with children's hair in it
either way kill meat tells me it tastes
just like chicken
with hair in it
children's hair but you were taking that
out i left it in come on what kind of
leader is he really
you can probably find that answer in a
tweet that he posted yesterday to
commemorate the only thing he has going
for him the january 6 riot or as i like
to call it ashley babbitt day yeah joe
put that in your ensure and drink it you
mummy
here's his tweet in full
i've said it many times and it is no
more true or real than when we think
about the events of january 6. we are in
a battle for the soul of america a
battle that by the grace of god and by
the goodness and greatness of this
nation we will win
so to quote gandhi what the [ __ ] is that
about
seriously this is kind of a big deal
because the president of the united
states just said we were in a battle for
the soul of america and that implies a
good side and a bad side right with two
teams which means if you're watching
this show and you like this show you're
probably on the bad team
so he's not including you in the we
so who is we him and jill him and kamala
him and his imaginary friend walter the
talking celery stick
is it liz cheney if she were any more of
a phony democrat she'd get an extra vote
in 2020 but the thing is it can't be all
americans right because then his premise
for that speech wouldn't make any sense
and the special day of commemoration
wouldn't be necessary because we'd all
be unified and he'd be a beloved
president and we'd all be dancing naked
in a meadow like brian kilmeaded steve
ducey on ketamine at the lilith fair
those were the days what so let's ask mr
no time to think
himself mr president you want to clarify
your comments on unity
look look look i was a little angry
yesterday but i sent what i meant all
right i i sent what i i meant what i
said
it was about the soul
of this country all right and i'm
telling you you better get on board on
board the
onboard the soul train
that's right
get
nice
it really is amazing
so if it's us versus them
who's them
it's us
not the germans or the japanese then
again who knows what year or century it
is in that scrambled egg he calls a mind
but he's made this claim on a fabricated
commemoration targeting his political
adversaries and democrats were saying
it's worse than pearl harbor and 9 11.
yes that might be the worst comparison
since the nfl is like slavery
but joe's defined himself against
something that doesn't even exist a
white supremacist movement a violent
insurrection none of that is real of
course he also tried to compare himself
against trump but trump's not even
president he's not even running against
joe so again joe's defining himself
against a mirage and why is that because
his leadership is a mirage a disaster on
four legs you can't get worse than joe
and cam so they need to distract by
demonizing you
and this from the administration that
brought you parents complaining about
schools are terrorists
but in that tweet and in that speech
yesterday he wasn't talking to us he was
talking about us and that's pretty gross
maybe i'm nuts but did joe just kind of
declare a civil war on a sizable portion
of america because i can't believe
he thinks we're at war with just one guy
like trump or a freak in a viking hat he
just pit one half of the country against
the other like he was picking sides for
a dodgeball game by the way he might not
even believe this crap because like his
bladder it's not him who's in control
but there are people in his white house
who believe were evil you and me because
you didn't vote for them maybe you voted
for the other guy who knows and now joe
uses january 6 to declare a war over the
soul of a country
so back to that question is joe a strong
leader well hard times are supposed to
bring out the best in men but what if
the best in one man is long gone and all
you have is a hollowed out husk open for
exploitation from any woke operative
but i guess when you collap collapse
afghanistan spike inflation and crime
and can't control corona all that's left
is creating a fake emergency it seems
like that's what we have right now and
when i say we i mean we the people as in
all americans and we all know that
there's no battle for the soul of this
country but the fact that the president
says it so should scare the crap out of
all of us
welcome tonight's
audience goes mad
his books are like christmas trees
headed to the landfill fox and friends
co-host and author of the great new book
the president and the freedom fighter
brian kill me thank you
you don't have to applaud yes i do no he
wants to rock and roll all night and
party on days approved by his parole
officer stand-up comedian and star of
bite the bullet on youtube jim
florentine
you can tell she grew up near portland
because she's a riot
pretty in pink host to kennedy on [ __ ]
business my favorite kennedy
except for douglas she's like your new
year's resolution already broken fox
news contributor cat tim
so brian in that poll that said 11 says
biden's a very strong leader 11 think
you're a decent human being but 89
think and this is a quote you should die
in a fiery collision between a train and
a semi i found that very specific
very specific and that was a write-in
everybody wrote in the same thing they
want to see you die in a fiery crash
between two different modes of
transportation do you mind if i talk to
the others for a second
i i was giving topics to prepare for
and they he made up a poll i was gonna
go back no no no good to see you
it's good to see you see that's what
blows me away is that uh he has an
opportunity i for a guy that has bad
leadership grades he's always alone yeah
you ever noticed that donald trump used
to come out with scientists yes
secretaries of state and national
security advisor jose was alone so it's
like not only is he they're putting him
out there to be a leader but people
don't accept him as a leader and he's
absent when it comes to new ideas so i
find this amazing because he did get
truthfully 89 million people oh i
thought
i like how you sneak in truthfully
you disgust me
dude why where did that come from
you want to show extreme emotion i
understand because that's what fuels
your show and your success and that's
fine a little bit later i'm going to
make up a poll too and you're going to
come out very poorly
but i've been waiting for you to make up
a poll for
ever right i'm pretty sure that was a
striptease joke am i right okay you have
to make money somehow right i'm just
about out of stuff to say because you
really didn't ask me a question but i
think one of the most important things i
take away here is he's off to a bad
start he's off to a very bad start thank
you for getting that that's why fox and
friends is four hours
three thanks for watching seems like
four yeah oh my god the cooking segments
just kill me right kennedy
you look great greg thank you so much
delicious i love your shoes why don't
you get you look great because she
she is in pink she's a much she's a
marvel in pink
what do you think biden's doing if he's
not thinking
i think
okay so you know as i was listening to
your monologue and i was thinking about
and and what you just said one of you
said it uh that trump used to come out
with you know all these different people
and experts i just said that yeah
deborah burks and anthony fauci and you
knew he was working because he was
spitballing while they were at a press
conference right normally people do that
kind of stuff like during the meeting
and then you come out and you get the
little memo and you're all on the same
page i miss that like i actually miss
you well okay so clorox is good for
cleaning stuff up but can you drink it
and they're like
but you knew like
at least he was kind of working and
curious you never
see the
operational side of joe biden's white
house and i i wish you would see you
know you you
stumbled into an interesting point
kennedy because you misinterpreted what
trump said because he's always
spitballing he actually was talking
about disinfectant light
not chlorides but a lot of people took
it as that because he would do this in
public
yes right but you knew he might and also
and he also sparred with the press in
real time yes he didn't have people like
i really would have so much respect for
joe biden if he came out yes and and
just took the gloves off and
had said said to the press didn't call
names just come at me for no what if he
took the gloves off and they were
skeletor hands just little
and he says
and then he flew away
on a magical satan slay
against ainsley earhart
jim how you doing
i'm doing good chopping down trees oh
yeah you like my uh
that's my cole's flannel i got for
christmas exactly i wanted to show it
off on tv yes you got the kohl's dollars
did you okay yeah i got it with free
calls dollars yeah i'm not allowed to
crash after the dressing room incident
but anyway what is what's you i've not
spoken to you in so long what is your
take on the biden administration right
now
well just at 11 think he's a strong
leader that means
89
think he's the wrong leader which is
scary yes you know um i don't know 11
yeah that's not uh that's now that seems
kind of high though really is that
including
is that including all the people from
the 1800s that voted for him
i don't know if they threw them in there
too but
look he doesn't have time to think i
know he's got a lot going on
you know he doesn't that's not his job
to think joe yeah it's a democrats job
to think for him so
you know look if he wants a job he
doesn't have to think i hear there's an
opening at the view yes there you go go
there yeah the view we forgot to insult
the view in the monologue what's going
on with that i don't know i let myself
go you know kat
uh do you have enough time to think when
you're here at fox news
yeah the thing is i'm always thinking
about thing like well i'm thinking like
what i'm thinking right now for example
nobody wants to know but like it's it's
you always are thinking right or maybe
he has one of those calm brains that
aren't always thinking but i would love
that but also i would love to have a
president who doesn't think at all if
that meant that they also didn't do
anything yes right because he not
thinking just sitting there i can do me
i can leave me alone i would love that
but it doesn't it's not his job to think
really because other people are the ones
making all the decisions all the time
what he talks about do you really do you
really want him to think no isn't it
good for him just to be on vacation far
far all the time all the time yeah but
then he's talking about the soul of the
country like countries don't have souls
okay yes and also nobody's soul is
supposed to be the government's business
that you're absolutely right that's so
true yeah like my soul big trouble but
that's gonna be my problem to deal with
in the afterlife yeah i mean it is and
it keeps is intimating a civil war brian
i mean you are an expert in that because
it could happen at any time in a fox and
friends because they hate you so much
there i did not know that oh yeah fox
and friends is basically a microcosm of
america right before the civil war i'm
told
so they'll go to you with this
information yeah
it's it's what's called in the business
an open secret
i wish i was in this business by the way
how great how
at one point you have a big picture a
big wall of joe biden yes she stopped
looking it was looking at joe biden and
kat was actually talking to joe biden's
picture during your uh little money like
right there you were you were actually
talking to him all right we got to move
on hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else